i love you i want you to know that
before we bust out our supersonic codes
want to give some love to the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by the quest for that home cinematic
audio experience that is to say sony's
hta 5000 soundbar and optional speakers
which the sound bar alone uses s force
pro front surround which creates
immersive cinema style surround without
the need for rear speakers but as we all
know apprentice there's a difference
between need and want so if you really
want to blow your hair back you can also
get the a series rear speakers and
subwoofer which then creates a bubble of
cinematic audio surround sound goodness
that embraces you as if to say enjoy
your pulse rate for the next two hours
or so
so click the link below to check out the
hta 5000 soundbar and accessories in
your quest for cinematic audio goodness
and now
[Music]
so sound like the hedgehog 2 is the
sequel to the surprisingly enjoyable
sonic the hedgehog movie which leads me
to think about one important question
what would knuckles and tails look like
if they had kept that original character
model
i shut her to think something at a pet
cemetery maybe a halloween special we'll
see but for sonic 2 we have dr robotnik
he has returned to earth once again
played by jim carrey and now we have
knuckles and tails and i want to be
honest with you idris elba as knuckles
was amazing he was as one great leader
once said a surprise to be sure but a
welcome one i just didn't expect it it's
like he's the surprise in this movie
that jim carrey was in the previous
movie i just didn't expect full-on 90s
jim carrey in the sonic the hedgehog
movie but there he was and it was great
knuckles in this movie is that fish out
of water he sees everything through the
lens
of everything has to be
a warriors contest and it just cracks me
up because he's kind of like drax in
that respect and it completely works he
is the standout in this movie the bummer
is
he very much overshadows tales and it
kind of overshadows the friendship
dynamic between sonic and tails i mean
it's in here but it doesn't feel as
profound as it probably should be not
putting all that on knuckles the human
beings in this movie definitely detract
from
the story as a whole and when this movie
was starting out and all the setup i had
the sensation of the first movie is
definitely superior to this there were
some missteps in this movie when it came
to the human beings and how they utilize
the humans in the movie because i mean
now you have knuckles comes into the
fold and robotnik well i mean he is a
human but you know he's still part of
the sonic world and you have tails and
sonic the hedgehog so you have enough
there to have a sonic movie just right
there it's like at this point you don't
need the humans anymore but the first
movie had them and now what do you do
with them you really feel like this
movie is wrestling with that whereas in
the first sonic movie you know the james
marston sonic the hedgehog dynamic was
actually a surprisingly enjoyable one
about friendship and family now it's
like all right we have enough to have a
sonic the hedgehog adventure
what do we do with the human and i feel
like they could have done a very real
thing about friendship or sonic now he
has tails as a friend
how does james marston like is he
wrestling with that i mean james marston
is he gonna be like oh am i losing a
friend is he is it gonna go away stop
don't care don't touch on any of that in
fact there's this whole side quest
dealing with a wedding in hawaii and for
the longest time in the movie though it
does tie back into the sonic adventure
it's not linked to the sonic adventure
you're just cutting from sonic tails
knuckles robotnik oh and over to this
other thing
you don't care funny enough this movie's
about 20 minutes longer than the first
movie and it feels 20 minutes longer
than the first movie and they could have
cut 20 minutes out of this movie that 20
minutes being everything involving the
human this movie also deals with what
the first movie dealt with i'm not going
to be too harsh on it because what can
you do when you have the fastest
creature in the universe you know there
are problems that arise in this movie
dealing with human beings and sonic is
so much faster than human beings and if
you remember that he was so much faster
than human beings he could actually do
the quicksilver thing that he actually
did in the first sonic movie he could
get out of these pickles but when it has
those moments of being an awesome sonic
movie it's an awesome sonic movie it's a
really fun time it's in here turns out
the movie's basically two movies a fun
solid sonic the hedgehog adventure on
one hand and a weird out-of-place
rom-com involving human beings who
aren't from the game all at a wedding in
hawaii however the movie does play it
smart and all my gripes and bitching
this video about the pacing and all the
irons and the fire and characters don't
really have a place in the movie for the
last act it focuses up and gives you all
that sonic goodness you came to the
movie for i say that smart because it
being the last act that's what it leaves
the audience with the audience walks out
going oh yeah that was a lot of fun and
that's where it leaves me being very
nice to this movie saying i still think
it's a fun family night out at the
movies no alcohol required what else
would it be family member of the movies
the flaws in my rating system rear its
ugly head again at the very least at
matinee price it's not as good as the
first movie but you know if you do it
matinee price i think that is fair all
right so sonic the hedgehog too have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite song with the
hedgehog game like before sonic mania
we're going old school here for me it
was always sonic 2 and then sonic cd or
something about that soundtrack sonic cd
they're just
good memories good times whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you